cet ensemble depuis sept ans c'est un
oui alors de 7 ans normalement le clash
mais normalement à le cap des sept ans
le fameux cap des ces camps alors à
faire un petit un petit bilan un petit
check up où est votre relation et on va
faire une interview omar ou fred
qui est le chef omar sy fred
bon ça c'est cyril lignac sur m6
qui négocient les contrats homard ou
fred c'est fred bref c'est moi ouais tu
es meilleur en compte at one way meyer
indique de droit ouais
j'ai réussi les examens en juin j'ai pas
eu la session de septembre
non mais c'est important qu'ils gagnent
le plus d'argent romain ou fred à lacets
aux marques ont trouvé là pourquoi là
parce qu'on l'a décidé ça il ya
longtemps c'était ma façon à moi de lui
comme tu négocies tu négocies mieux pour
moi ouais chaque
pas surtout cesser politique c'est à
dire que moi c'est ma façon de lutter
contre le racisme
blanc qui gagne moins qu'un noir oui
mais c'est mieux je donne les trois
quarts voilà à les trois cas qui a baisé
mademoiselle agnès omar sy fred
tu sais la réponse ouais c'est vikash
dhorasoo
et chiant quand même
c'est pas nous
qui est le plus heureux dans la vie on a
row fred c'est moi oui parce que je joue
dans nos jours heureux qui sent le 28
juin à une rue midi c'est dans la série
la double promouvrait de sel clooney la
télé
lighting de brevets moi je suis d'ici
qui est vraiment moins bon sans l'autre
omar sy fred je sens moins bon sens
commun ça c'est vrai et c'est tout le
monde le sait voilà qui a déjà voulu
tout arrêter omar fred zinedine zidane
la reine c'est vrai mais c'est lui qui
arrête malheureusement pour nous
quel plus peur que tout s'arrête omar au
fred dominique de villepin
qui est le plus drôle omar sy fred
ce fret
pourquoi parce qu'il est plus drôle en
tout cas me fait plus rire que je me
fais rire moi même en tout cas
j'espère que tu as la maladie de la
rigolote et ça s'est toujours fait
soigner d'ailleurs pas d'entente mais
fait rire
il pourra rien en même temps qu'elle
plus d'amis dans le showbiz main ou fred
c'est ma gloire
qui a les plus belles gonzesses omar sy
fred c'est omar parce que il y en a deux
magnifiques ouais c'est un petit peu la
séquence émotion c'est vrai et je n'ai
jamais dit mais ses fils les plus belles
robes ça me fait plaisir elle sent
comment elles sont belles oui et non
benoît nortier elles se disent métis
mathis l'avenir de l'homme l'a décrit
thierry ardisson oui
j'ai pas de 6 à marine le pen qui vient
de sortir on est tout chamboulé
qui baisent le plus
omar ou fred ben c'est moi j'ai des
enfants et pas lui
ouais j'ai baisé trois fois
à me dire comment faire
pipi comme trop omar sy fred ça c'est
michel piccoli
c'est obligé c'est obligé car j'ai de
mon sens c'est important d'être jeux de
mots des fois dans des émissions bien
cela fait toujours un peu d'exercice
qui picolent chez piccoli
qui a dit le premier je t'aime à l'autre
omar sy fred
c'est moi un oui bah c'est lui le
premier qui a été le plus c'est à cannes
entre à 20 18
c'est le premier qui m'a un petit peu
chicoter il va bouleverser
tout de suite
pour entrer dans les détails qui perd
ses cheveux omar sy fred marc olivier
fogiel
et
à l'ego le plus dimensionné homard ou
fred malaisien fogel
qui ne plus capricieux des de homard ou
fred marc ollivier le projet
qui reçoit le plus de lettres de fans
suivent à marc olivier fogiel annoncé
séverine ferrer
tapotage ah le fameux capotage qui prend
le plus de drogues homard ou fred alors
là non là vraiment par contre c'est une
question qui nous font nous c'est
l'autre avait presque réponse parce que
nous on se drogue à la vie voilà et je
sais que des larmes
l'émotion
c'est droit de réguler n'est pas facile
à dire la tenir ouais mais c'est vrai
rien du tout nous venons rien typé tard
quand même jamais thierry non non
ils ont retrouvé pas c'est ça
qui est le plus bel organe
clichés
ouais je crois que les cubains
qui de plus engagé politiquement en
marron fred
parce qu'ils jeu nelson mandela jeunes
auxquels groupe
qui a le plus d'amis noir au marron fred
assez mois ouhlala ouais moi j'ai du mal
qui est plus cochon amour mari fred je
ne mange pas de porc
qui a les plus grosses voitures omar
fred mais j'ai trois enfants ah ouais
j'ai un break
qui s'est tapé catherine deneuve vikash
dhorasoo et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu